Charlotte North Carolina starts off this
hour CID is on the line hi said how are
you I'm doing well Dave thanks for
asking how are you today better than I
deserve what's up well you know I've
been a longtime listener luckily had
parents that instilled great money
plenty spending habits made me read
financial piece before I had an
opportunity to get off to college and
I've gotten myself into a student loan
situation hoping I could get some advice
on it
my fiance and I sat down recently at we
both graduated from law school currently
have about 225 thousand dollars in
student loans we went to a private law
school and we're really trying to figure
out how to best tackle this you know
we're currently on an income based plan
we make right at about $80,000 combined
income and I'm having a hard time seeing
the financial incentive of paying more
than just that income based because I'm
not really ever unless I pay more than
$2,000 a month I don't really ever have
an opportunity to attack the principal
I'm just constantly paying down on the
interest so I'm confused you went to law
school to make $40,000 a year the rest
of your life they didn't tell me that
when I signed the line but as a first
year at the first year associate that is
that is unfortunately the going rate so
I wasn't arguing the first year
associate stuff but you just projected
this out 10 years with your hopelessness
true yes sir
and so I mean do for second year
associates only make 40 grand well you
know I fourth year lawyers that are
successful only make 40 grand probably
not to probably double it at that time I
would hope more than double yes I ought
to be in six figures four years out
especially with your private school
education yes sir okay so I mean first
year they try to kill you that's the job
that's the rule I mean especially if
you're going with a big firm right their
goal is just to completely destroy you
during that year it's almost like boot
camp or something and they're gonna
they're you're probably make a dollar
and
you know and but then after that you pay
it you're paying that price not to live
like that your whole life but to never
have to live like that again right right
and so yeah you're going to tread water
this year financially on your student
loans but when you're making a tea you
won't be treading water and when you're
making 120 as a pair or 240 as a pair
both of you working you know we're going
to clean this up really really quickly
right so how right so how do I at this
time keep my trying to keep my head
above the water because the way I'm
looking at it I'm about almost twenty
posted $20,000 in interest a year on
both of these loans let me ask you this
what set of logic did you use when you
took out the loans well at the time I've
been able to keep my loans very low I
worked jobs and and luckily had parents
that were willing to help me so my loans
are very low what are your loan my loans
are right at $21,000 okay so your wife
has two hundred thousand dollars and you
learned that my soon-to-be wife has
about two hundred and she's got about
two hundred and seven kept up well let
me just tell you part of my soon-to-be
wife's discussion is she's going to be
working like baby's condom she's working
more babies come she's still working she
doesn't have a choice right because you
guys have got to get your income up in
that $200,000 range very quickly so
here's the thing I mean I guess I would
pose the same question to her or to you
this way what would you think was going
through her head when she did that
probably not a lot but hopefully what
she was at least rationalizing this
ridiculous deal that she got herself
into is that she's going to make a lot
of money as a lawyer later and it'll be
easy to pay this back right right that's
at least what some had that at least as
a passing thought and so my point with
that is that's probably somewhat true
it's a pain in the butt that doesn't
justify this ridiculous situation but
you're there now there's no sense
yelling at you about that so the trick
is you guys keep your lifestyle at 40
thousand bucks and every time you make
41 you throw an extra thousand then when
you make 61 you throw 21 thousand at it
and when you make eighty one you throw
forty one thousand at it and you keep
your lifestyle at forty
you're not real lawyers you're broke
lawyers and you keep acting that way you
keep living like a college student in
other words and you clean these things
up as fast as you can so you're not
going to continue to accrue interest
forever because you're not going to make
this income forever you've got to get
your incomes up overall so you're not
taking a job doing pro bono work in the
inner city as a charity you're too
freakin broke to do that [ __ ] search
okay I just do it on the side when I can
well I'm not saying it's a bad thing
you just have it you have an obligation
to the two of you to clean this mess up
so that later you can be charitable all
right but you're going to have to
concentrate on one thing right now for
the next five years and that's make
money it's time to get the pay off so
should i in in this in the next four to
five years obviously I should try and be
as aggressive as I possibly can with
paying down on the interest no I just on
the debt in general right I mean the
first thing you do is you're throwing
money at the debt is you cover the
interest you're not quite doing that yet
so the right as you raise what you're
paying on the debt the first thing
that's going to occur is you're going to
pay more and more interest how much are
you paying on how much you paying the
mail on this income base crap on the
income-based she pays 300 like three
hundred and forty dollars a month and
I've paid for my full year of what my
loan payments would have been at the
very beginning of the year I just I try
and pay it all off at the beginning of
the year so I don't have to keep this
machine that's not twenty thousand her
interest rate is what six percent so
she's paying $12,000 zero percent huh
seven point eight percent seven point
eight percent so she's got a fifteen
thousand dollar interest payment per
year and she's currently paying four
thousand dollars right so you're not
you're not accruing twenty thousand
you're accruing eleven thousand a year
right yes okay yes that's correct
so it's not nearly quite that dramatic
although we are
going the wrong direction so the first
11,000 more that you guys pay on this is
going to get you to break-even okay and
then in the next 11,000 is going to be
the principle reduction right right yes
that's correct and you just keep your
lifestyle at 40,000 you're not buying
furniture you're not going on vacation
you are not going out to eat you get to
pay back private student loans saltine
crackers and you got it Burdine ramen
noodles and you know we're living like
we're broke while we're lawyers and that
that's the trip that she signed up for
and when you put the ring on her finger
that's the trip you're signing up for
it's not a it's not the other world it's
not a deal breaker but you guys have got
to pay a price to win here because
otherwise you're going to keep these
things around you're gonna look up 10-15
years from now this crap still going to
be going on it's still going to be
making decisions for you and you're
still going to be experiencing that the
borrower is slave to the lender so you
just got to keep this as front and
center keep the main thing the main
thing is they say but congratulations on
your upcoming wedding and in on your
future success I think it will happen
for you you're a smart guy
you guys got to pay a price dude there's
no goofing around here this is the Dave
Ramsey show